the gyro gun experience I think William
James was one of the one of the guys who
really did a good job of that saying
basically you know if I may be right
about this way of thinking but even if
I'm not thinking this way allows me to
lead a better life and I think he was
talking about freewill and he was
basically saying look I don't know if we
have free will or I don't know if
everything we do is based on a causal
chain of events that we really can't
control but thinking about freewill in a
way that it does exist allows me to live
a better life and so guess what I am a
proponent of freewill because that
allows me to live a better life that way
because I feel like I have more
flexibility more choice I'm a happier
person and I think sometimes people
forget some of that too you know I mean
there's something to be said for
thinking about things even if you don't
know you know think about things in in a
way that's gonna allow you to lead the
best life and you know way better than
if you don't know anyways you think
about something in a way that fucking
sucks like I'm gonna go to hell for sure
well if you're wrong in that you've
lived a life being afraid and being
worried about shit and you were wrong
might as well think in a positive way
and still you still may turn out to be
wrong but hey along the way you lived in
a better way yeah sounds like someone's
starting a cult that's what I just heard
I heard obvious yeah
no no doubt man I mean there's uh III
think it's couldn't it might not be
either/or as well it might be another
one of those situations yeah you know it
uh it there's I think there's a lot of
things going on there's a lot of things
going on this life and I think we should
acknowledge all of them you know we
should acknowledge the most importantly
the mystery of it all that's one of the
big things that drives me crazy about
someone when they say you know that this
is this and that is that and the you
know the way you should live is this and
the way the government should do is that
and the way we're gonna solve this is by
that like maybe not maybe not like are
you are you really so sure that you're
paying attention to what the fuck is
going on we're flying through space like
we're on a spaceship if the spaceship
was a hundred feet wide you'd be
freaking the fuck out right now the only
reason why you're not freaking out is
because it's like thousands of miles
but it's still a spaceship you're on a
spinning fuckin thing and at nighttime
you could see the space you're flying
through and you're spending a thousand
miles an hour in a circle and you're
floating around this giant nuclear
explosion and that's around other bigger
rocks that are flying behind you and gas
giants and then other galaxies and other
universes and on and on and you're just
hurtling through it while you're worried
about what's on TV and why the Walking
Dead has so many commercials and why gas
is for two hours and if you imagine if
this was let's say put yourself in a
position where this really was a dream
and you had a lucid dream where you're
aware you know is that what you would
want to do with your dream if you were
going to sleep at night and you were
saying you would worry about all of
these inane things never actually be in
the present moment never take an
adventure never go on a risk never love
because you could get hurt no if you if
this if you really did treat this like a
dream you would do as much cool shit as
possible
you know and put is put as many good
things into that dream as you possibly
could and not not be so fucking stressed
out about all this nonsense you know and
and I think we've been talking a lot
it's kind of been the theme of this
podcast but if you actually did if this
was a lucid dream you know you would
live it in a different way you would
live it to have some fun and enjoy
you're like what can I fly so my lucid
dreams I want to fly or breathe
underwater
breathe underwater is cool - that's a
good one yeah it would be very strange
if one day as it was proven that we are
really living in some sort of self
created reality it would be like really
traumatizing for a lot of people that
have fucked it up like this is what I
made but it's like remember when you
were in school and like there was a
project and you had to use your hand to
make a turkey and you put your hand down
and you drew around and then you know
everybody did their own little turkey
painted it and then the teacher would
put them up and they would all look at
him some people's turkeys look like
dogshit
it looked I didn't know what the fuck a
turkey looked like they didn't even know
how to draw around their hand like
everything was a disaster and other
people had beautiful turkeys well your
life is a work of art you your life is
like a hand turkey that you make and
great school it's you could do whatever
you want with that thing you can make it
super dope ya know you can you can make
it so it looks really cool if you put
the effort and time into it if you
really focus on it or you could just
have
fast that motherfucker and draw a bunch
of squiggly things don't look anything
like fingers some eyeballs that are
floating above a stupid fake turkey head
yeah and everybody's like what the
fuck's wrong with Bob I think one of the
one of the coolest pieces that I've seen
and I have to go to the bathroom so I
don't know if you want to know but it's
Alan it's called Alan Watts inception is
the name of the video on Google oh yeah
that's a great video